welcome to serverless Expeditions Luca
thank you Martin thanks for inviting me
of course so Martin I've heard up the
Grapevine that you're looking to explore
CI CD for serverless products in Google
Cloud yep uh to note though Luca all of
my code will eventually live in GitHub
so I need something that integrates well
with GitHub and our other services and
the less code I have to write the better
got it I could definitely relate sounds
like a great use case for Google GitHub
actions
[Music]
you mentioned GitHub actions Luca how do
they work sure thing Martin let me show
you a quick example so here is a simple
Cloud function Martin it leverages
GitHub actions to automate unit tests
and redeployments to gcp I'll make a
small change deploy to the main branch
and let's see what happens okay Luca
just going to add a quick comment to our
serverless function here and after
saving let's deploy this change
since all of my CI CD steps live in
GitHub actions I could watch each of
them hopefully complete here
very automated Luca I like it Google
interactions are pretty powerful right
yeah uh but what about Cloud build in
Google Cloud I've heard that we could
just do the same thing like you did here
in Google Cloud instead of in GitHub oh
yeah there's so many ways you can
accomplish CI CD this is just one
pattern
let me ask you one question you said you
have a few different services do you
mean across multiple Cloud platforms
exactly uh there are cross multiple
Cloud platforms on Google Cloud we have
a cloud run service and we also have a
few services on other clouds I see
as it relates to Google cloud is there a
reason you are looking into a CI CD
offering and not doing CD through the
native Cloud build integration
yes we use the cloud build integration
with Source repos hosted in Google Cloud
currently however we want to implement
both CI and CD to orchestrate this
across all our services and not just
those in Google Cloud
gotcha that makes sense I'd say if
you're focused primarily on the cloud
run service then letting Google Cloud
Drive continuous delivery as we
mentioned here
would be an awesome option something
else I'm curious about Martin are you
using a single monorepo for all of your
services yep we are and that will all
soon be up on GitHub perfect given that
everything is Consolidated into GitHub
you have Services across a few different
clouds and there are CI steps to take
before deployment GitHub actions would
be a great fit
sounds good how do I get started Luca
sure thing Martin let's jump into your
monorepo on GitHub and we can walk
through a workflow with GitHub actions
all right uh here is my source repo and
in this subdirectory I have a simple
node.js service that I would like to
redeploy to cloudron whenever new code
is committed and this service parses the
sentiment of messages from a pub sub
push subscription
uh but anyway how do I deploy my
cloudron servers here from GitHub great
question and we have a few options for
you if you already have gcloud deploy
scripts you are using today
Google GitHub actions team has pre-built
actions that authenticate to Google
cloud and set up gcloud for you then you
can take your existing deploy script and
run it as a workflow step
sounds convenient but some of our team
is not as familiar with the gcloud
command line tool as I am are there
other options where you don't have to
use that definitely we have an even
simpler solution package actions for a
variety of services that Google Cloud
provides like Cloud run gke and Cloud
functions all you have to do is create a
step point it to this action input the
necessary parameters and our action will
do all the heavy lifting for you that is
just what we're looking for okay how can
I get started with those packaged
actions in GitHub that you mentioned I
see an actions tab here is that a good
place to start yep clicking on that tab
will take you to the actions Marketplace
here you can find a plethora of starter
workflow templates to bootstrap your CI
CD we have a few starter workflows
readily available let's search for cloud
run that's awesome and these GitHub
actions look at they are managed by the
Google Cloud team yeah they're all
official Google Cloud Integrations for
the GitHub actions Marketplace
definitely recommend to always check the
source of the actions that you're using
in this specific case the repo shows the
organization has been verified as being
from Google
great
okay it looks like there is a deploy
from Source or deploy from Docker
eventually we'll want to manage our own
Docker file but for now I'll select the
deploy from Source option yep
okay great now let me click on that
wow it looks like a lot was generated
for me
yeah the starter templates are great
quick to get started plus they will
generate all of the directory and
relevant workload steps for you I see uh
you mentioned workflow steps okay uh can
you walk me through the developer
workflow here sure thing at a high level
GitHub actions is a way to do cicd on
GitHub you don't write a bunch of code
it starts with a yaml file inside that
yaml file you will define activities
that should occur based on events that
can happen for example think about a
common repo event like when you push to
a branch you would have a series of
steps that should happen running unit
tests linting and then a deployment
got it and all that that you mentioned
that is CI CD right exactly in GitHub
terms that series of steps Define a
workflow to execute the yaml file is
where you configure that workflow and
GitHub then automates that gotcha this
is very neat okay I see that the starter
template tells me how to set up
permissions and accounts in my world
Cloud project to make this work
yes we want to make it as easy as
possible for people to get started with
our actions
excellent so look I already have a
service account with a required IAM
permissions and the relevant apis are
enabled as well but I'm not familiar
with the workload identity Federation
step here what is that and is it even
required no it's not necessarily
workload identity Federation is more
secure and it works better with some org
policies but it requires a bit more
setup we can get you started with a
simple service account key today
let's talk about workload identity
Federation in a future episode all right
Luke that sounds good uh I'll grab the
service account key here then
perfect I have my service account key
now where can I securely store this in
GitHub so if you navigate to the repo
settings page and click on actions we
can securely store your credentials
there
all right I see thank you Luca uh I'll
just name this S A creds for short
great so looking into the yaml file here
it looks like there are a few
environment variables I need uh what are
these are these the ones that I set with
argument Flags if I run gcloud run
deploy exactly
these environment variables are going to
be passed to the deploy Cloud run action
as inputs we can hard code them in the
action step as well but it's nice to
have them exported as environment
variables at the top of the file for
readability
oh okay let me fill in those
all right
Thanks Martin let's also comment out the
workload identity Federation auth step
and use the service account off step
instead
great uh now how does GitHub actions
reference the secret that we saved
earlier
so any variables or Secrets referenced
in the workflow file GitHub extends a
variable Syntax for let's look at a few
examples
got it that's easy to pick up uh let me
make that change
I say creds all right
anything else before deploying here look
out the last step we will need to do is
update the source input of the action to
the relative path of our node.js service
ah right uh let me update that
deploy all right so I have one question
for you here Luca uh when this workflow
is triggered where are these operations
being run on Whose server yep either it
runs on a virtual machine that GitHub
spins up for you or one that you
self-host
ah there's a self-hosting option too
that is great ah looks like my cloud run
service was deployed awesome let's
quickly test it out in the cloud console
all right I'm going to publish a brief
message to the pub sub topic uh let's
see if the service can accurately assess
the message sentiment uh Luca what do
you think about pineapple on pizza
hmm in all honesty Martin actually a big
fan
oh uh I might have other opinions about
pineapple and pizza but it looks like a
service run a good sentiment overall
this is great it's pretty awesome right
yes and the fact that it can have this
as a build step without having to manage
deploy scripts or have it run after my
continuous integration it's very
convenient this fits all my requirements
of being integrated with GitHub other
Cloud providers in Google cloud and most
important of all low code
definitely agree we want to make it as
easy as possible for developers on
GitHub to integrate CI CD for gcp
products great thank you everyone for
tuning in if you like this video please
subscribe below and leave a comment and
don't forget to tune in for the future
video we will authenticate our Google
GitHub action workflow more securely
with workflow identity Federation bye
for now
[Music]
thank you